- [Mark] All right.
So, it's Ocean, or Oshe,
how do I pronounce your name?
- Ocean or Oceanian.
Oceanian, like the ocean?
- [Mark] Yes, got it.
- What do you like
better Ocean or Oceanian?
- [Mark] They're both
beautiful, but Oceanian.
- Everyone calls me Ocean but.
My clothing line's called Oceanian Banana.
- [Mark] Oh! I see, it's a clothing line.
- Well, my name is Oceanian.
So, my clothing line is Oceanian Banana
by Oceanian Peel. (laughs)
- [Mark] I'm going with Oceanian.
- Isn't that lit?
- [Mark] All right Oceanian,
Oceanian where'd you
grow up, where you from?
- I'm from Fort Smith, Arkansas.
- [Mark] Arkansas.
- Hmm.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both of your parents growing up?
- I'm adopted.
- [Mark] Okay.
- And my adopted father passed away
from cancer and heart
disease, and my mom is 80.
(laughs)
- [Mark] Okay, and how was your childhood?
- It was cool, um I had
six,
hold on, five brothers and
sisters adopted, all adopted.
(laughs)
- [Mark] So, a good
childhood? No crazy news?
- (laughs)
This is so crazy, I've
always had to, like,
hide my, like, childhood,
but, like, I'm talking about it right now.
But, it was cool, it's just a lot of like,
what's it, fighting and stuff sometimes.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And, yeah.
- [Mark] But like, physical, sexual abuse,
anything like that?
- Um, my brother, my
older brother molested me
when I was, like,
14.
- [Mark] Hmm.
- I think 13 or 14 maybe
younger, I can't remember.
It definitely was like the
beginning of middle school.
So, it goes like, middle school,
high school. Middle school.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Yeah.
And then he was molested
by his, our older brother,
who was gay, so.
- [Mark] Oh wow.
- Yeah. (laughs)
And that was his excuse
to do it to me I guess,
and I eventually forgave him,
he's a marine now, so, we kinda talk.
- [Mark] Cool.
- And stuff, yeah.
- [Mark] Forgiveness is great.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- [Mark] And a-
- It's cool, he apologized so many times,
and I just finally was like, "It's okay."
- [Mark] That's great.
- I forgive him, yeah.
- [Mark] That's really nice.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- [Mark] And, where'd your
life go when you left home?
- I really wanted to go
to college really bad.
And I graduated homeschool,
'cause I got kicked out of every school,
I was a troublemaker growing up.
Like, I got kicked out
of school so many times,
like, no district around
my house would take me.
- [Mark] Oh wow.
- They were like, they were like
"No like, she can't come."
I'm like "Duh duh duh."
So, I ended up going to,
like a, continuation school,
and I got kicked out of that. (laughs)
And I just was home schooled after that.
And I got all A's and B's and I was like,
"I wanna go to college so bad."
And I didn't want to
go to regular college,
so I went to fashion school.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Dropped out of that really fast,
I was just partying every day.
Working and partying.
Yeah.
- [Mark] So, your working
currently as like-
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How would you describe this?
- Like, I would say, like a,
I don't say it like, high end escort.
Like, are you an escort,
or like, you know,
a hooker?
- [Mark] You entertain men.
- I usually, yeah I think I
say I'm a, like a entertainer.
I get paid to entertain, or like-
or I'm a sugar baby.
- [Mark] There you go.
- But, at the end of the
day, it's all the same thing.
(laughs)
- [Mark] And how many years
have you been doing this?
- Since college.
- [Mark] Since college?
- Yeah, like, my mom and my family
was living off of the check
that you get for being adopted,
and also elderly, like,
she had her check too.
So, when I moved for college,
I couldn't take the money,
it's like that's how my mom pays her rent.
- [Mark] Right.
- So, I really needed to have a job.
And I think I borrowed $50 or
$100 from my sister one time,
and I felt really bad 'cause
it was her FAFSA money.
And I was like, "No
I never want to ask my
mom for money again,
or my sister, or anyone."
So, this girl, my roommate
got me into it, actually.
- [Mark] And this was still in Arkansas?
- No, I moved to LA. (laughs)
- [Mark] Oh, this was in LA?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- [Mark] Okay.
- Yeah. I moved to LA,
and I went to school
for like three months,
and then I dropped out.
But like, two of the months,
or like, one of the months,
I didn't even go to class, it was like,
and then I just dropped out.
I was like "I'm not going back." (laughs)
- [Mark] So, because your working on a-
- I was working like everyday
just to pay to live in
the student housing.
And then art school's more expensive to me
than normal college,
'cause you have to buy
all these, like, supplies.
The assignments, you get
like, seven assignments,
'cause I was in seven
classes, full time student.
And then, I didn't get
along with my roommates,
'cause they were all like
big and scary and mean.
(laughs)
And I didn't hang out with them
'cause I was working, you know?
And they couldn't go with me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- 'Cause I was like, high end.
(laughs)
And like, they didn't like that,
and they would always pick on me,
and like try and fight me.
So, I just didn't want
to go to school anymore,
I was like over it.
(laughs)
- [Mark] So, you make good
money doing this, right?
- I've been on my own since I was 17,
without any experience of doing anything,
my mom never let me
out of the house, ever.
Like, you know, I was completely
like, just went to college,
kind of like a virgin.
(laughs)
And,
yeah.
- [Mark] And, so-
- And I just feel like
I'm so good at what I do,
'cause my first job
was high end escorting,
but then I wanted to get a job, you know?
And I worked at Guess,
and I made, like, top seller of the month,
like, when I worked there,
like, you know what I mean?
And I was like, "This is bullshit."
Like, I was like, "I can
make so much more money.
I'm wasting my time. I'm so pretty.
Everyone thinks I'm a
model. Let me just do it."
And then I started modeling
for like, Playboy, and like,
getting into things like that.
And I think it works out
with the high end escorting
'cause you need pictures,
to get gigs sometimes.
- [Mark] Yeah, they overlap
quite a bit don't they?
- You know, so, it was like, fun.
And I learned about makeup
and like, dressing up.
I actually enjoy it. (laughs)
- [Mark] So your clientele,
they treat you nicely, you don't-
- I mean, everyone's
been, I think had their,
like, times, or whatever,
and I definitely have had
some crazy, wild stories.
And I feel like, lately
though, I've been good,
like, treated-
- [Mark] But your not getting,
like a lot of the girls
that work Figueroa, for
example, or whatever, they-
- I know some girls that actually,
like, worked the streets.
But, I don't do that.
- [Mark] But down there
you'll get guys raping you,
and doing all kind of terrible-
- Oh my god.
- [Mark] Terrible things.
- Really? Wow.
- [Mark] Your not seeing that,
because your at this other level.
- Yeah, not like that.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Never seen-
- [Mark] No, I mean, but,
you'll be in casinos, or-
- Yeah, things like that.
I mean I've definitely had
the GHB drug or whatever,
you know, and,
but I don't remember anything.
(laughs)
- [Mark] Yeah, I guess you
wouldn't remember anything.
- Oh my god, that is so funny.
- [Mark] Have you been arrested ever?
- Yes.
Not for being a high end escort,
but I drive a lot of nice,
fast cars all the time,
and I'm always like really cute with like,
super sounds.
'Cause I modeled for like this car shows,
and they gave me these sound system.
So, my car like,
is really loud and it's
just super dope and fast.
And I always get pulled over,
and I end up going to jail
'cause I've never had a drivers license.
And then when I finally got
one, like a year or two ago,
I got it taken away, and I don't have one.
So, I go to jail sometimes
for driving, it's crazy.
- [Mark] Yeah, but, not prostitution?
- No. (laughs)
Just for driving.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So, your family knows you do this?
Or, your mom?
- Yeah, I mean, yeah, I told my mom,
I think I've always told my mom what I do.
Like, you know, she
didn't like it at first,
she tried to talk me into
going back into school
and whatever.
And like, "I didn't raise you like this
and your Christian."
It was kind of bad, like, we
weren't talking for a minute,
but we're fine now.
- [Mark] But, the way you speak about it,
I don't get feeling, like
this is a terrible thing
that you just have to do.
- I think she realized that
I'm actually like, really good.
She saw me on TV a couple
times for modeling.
I have a store in Vegas.
I make the money stripping.
And then I'm a high end
escort and I look really cute
when I do it.
And I hang out with, like,
really successful people.
- [Mark] Yeah, but your smiling,
and laughing and having a good time.
- Yeah, and I think it made her feel like,
"Okay, it's okay."
- [Mark] Your not crying
telling these stories of-
- Oh no. Mm mm.
I've cried and told her stories before,
but not recently, I
think I meant, (laughs)
- [Mark] Does doing this for a
living ever get you down, or-
- Oh my god, yeah.
It does, only because I feel, like
I just feel like I really want
to, like, have a house with kids, and
you know, but I just feel
like I'm not there yet.
- [Mark] A more stable life?
- I need to be more stable, and like,
more appropriate.
I don't want to raise kids that way.
- [Mark] Yeah, the
lifestyle your living in is-
- They definitely would
see something, and,
I just, kids really
me, and the way I look.
And they already like, always ask me like,
what I'm wearing, they follow me around,
you know what I mean, they talk about me.
I just feel like if I had a kid,
like, she's going to watch me,
and like see what I'm doing,
and kind of like how I walk, whatever.
And like she's going to
end up doing those things.
I just wouldn't do that to
someone right now, no. (laughs)
Yeah.
- [Mark] And what, your customers
are what kind of people?
What kind of guys?
- Always older men, usually,
older than me.
- [Mark] That are probably
married, sometimes?
- Mm hm, married, older men, successful,
fun. (laughs)
Interesting men.
- [Mark] The sexual
interactions you'll have
are typically normal and pretty standard,
or does it get into like, fetish?
- It gets into like, we, Yeah, like, I've,
I think I'm finally okay
with doing those things.
But, in the beginning,
it was so hard, like-
- [Mark] What's the weirdest
thing you've been asked to do?
- The weirdest thing
I've been asked to do?
Oh my god.
The weirdest thing.
I feel like, the weirdest
thing I've had to do
was have sex with this girl.
Like, this guy asked me
to fuck her in the ass
with a strap on.
(laughs)
And like, when I was doing
it, I was so high that I like,
thought I was a guy for
a second, and I was like,
stroking the strap on,
and I was like, "Whoa."
'Cause there was a mirror
right there, you know?
And I'm just like totally
was into it for a second.
And I'm like wait, I'm not a guy.
(laughs)
It was kind of fun, interesting.
I made a lot of money.
- [Mark] And he was watching?
- He was watching.
I guess he wanted to prove
his girlfriend was a lesbian.
- [Mark] Oh, it was his girlfriend
that you were having fun with?
- And then like, he ended
up committing suicide like,
not even like weeks after
I went over to his house.
It was so weird.
And I was just like, yeah.
I don't feel comfortable sometimes
doing little jobs like that.
(laughs)
Not trying to hurt anyone.
- [Mark] And are drugs a
part of the picture for you?
- I used to do drugs, all drugs.
Like, anything, I've tried
everything, almost everything.
But, I don't do drugs 'cause
my real mom does drugs,
and I just feel like I don't
want to be like my real mom.
- [Mark] Your biological-
- My real parents, that's
why I got taken away,
they do drugs, yeah.
Sell drugs, and do drugs.
And I just really didn't want to do that.
But, I smoke weed all
the time and I drink,
but that's it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- But I used to do like,
coke, molly, all that.
(laughs)
I've tried everything.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Have you been in love before?
- Yeah, I do feel like I've been in love.
- [Mark] I'm wondering how
this lifestyle interferes with-
- I didn't realize I was in
love with someone until like,
I got into this.
So, it just doesn't work
out, you know what I mean?
So, that's why I'm still
doing this and like-
- [Mark] It would be very
difficult to have this lifestyle-
- [Oceanian] And be in love.
So, I'm really not focused
on like, love right now.
I am just focused on like
companionship I guess.
Like, you know, like maybe
like a friend or a partner
I could trust and hang out with
and like, you know.
Yeah. (laughs)
But, other that that, like,
I'm not trying to have kids right now, or-
- [Mark] And how old are you?
- [Oceanian] I'm 25.
- [Mark] Your 25?
- [Oceanian] Yeah.
- [Mark] So, your still very young.
- [Oceanian] Yeah, I
think I'll probably be
in this lifestyle till
I'm like 30, to be honest.
Because, I love traveling,
I've been to like so many countries,
and like, I feel like guys
love paying for girls travel.
And like, I can't do
that with a boyfriend,
I really tried it and
it's like, miserable.
- [Mark] So your customers,
the guys you call customers,
will sometimes fly you to-
- All the time.
Like, they fly me places,
they pay my bills,
they feed me, they take care of my dog,
they clean for me, they,
all that stuff.
Bought me boobs, you know?
Fix my car, buy me jewelry.
Like,
like. (laughs)
Yeah, it's fun.
(laughs)
I think at first, when I
first started, I was scared.
Like, the first time I had
to go do it, I was so scared.
And then, like, I did it a few times,
I started crying, and I never
did it again for a minute.
But then I did it again.
I just always just kept doing it again.
Getting normal jobs, doing
it again, doing it again.
And now, I'm just like, I've
been just doing it, like.
Everyone like loves it too.
All my girlfriends and I do it together.
Like, you know what I mean?
- [Mark] So, your making
it sound very appealing,
and I'm just,
I like to get all these
different perspectives.
What advice or what words
of wisdom would you share
with a young girl who's
seeing your interview,
and thinking, "Wow, this
doesn't seem so bad?"
- Don't do it.
(laughs)
Don't be a high end escort.
But, if it's your only option,
and your already kinda
in a situation like that,
I would say get help.
Like, if they have a lot
of money can help you.
Why not ask for some help.
You don't have to do it in a you know,
aggressive way, you could just
do it in a nice friendly way.
Fun, sexy, cute way.
- [Mark] With males that like you.
- I feel like that's how I do it.
Like, I do it in a very
slick, like, sexy, cute way.
It just comes off natural
rather than it being like,
you know, hey boy.
- [Mark] And the men
kind of take care of you,
and you have some fun.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And no one gets hurt.
- No one gets hurt.
I'm always very careful and nice,
and clean and my friends are safe.
Like, we always get high you know?
- [Mark] It sounds like you
haven't had bad experiences.
- I've had a couple bad experiences.
Like, where I, Like I told you, GHB.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And you know.
Just seeing pictures the next day
of me and like scratches
and like little flashbacks,
and waking up to having
someone on me, you know?
But, not really knowing what happened
'cause I was blacked out.
Things like that, so I don't really have
that like super traumatic.
And I have been like, like not kidnapped,
girls would say kidnapped, but
I have, I got tricked into being like,
living with the pimp and his girlfriend.
'Cause this girl was like,
"Come live my penthouse,"
and I was like, "Oh my
god, like, I really want
to live in a penthouse."
My ex dumped me, like, I'm like
you know, I'm couch surfing,
like, why not?
So I moved in, and as soon as I moved in
it was like, I got beat up,
the sim card was taken out of my phone.
- [Mark] You have had
some bad experiences?
- Like, the phone
numbers were all deleted.
I had nobody's number but my mom.
I'm not going to tell
my mom what happened.
Like, she's 80.
Like, I'm not gonna tell her,
she'll have a heart attack.
So, I just ended getting back with my ex.
He's the only person the number I had.
And so, even though we
broke up and I left him,
'cause we broke up, he kicked me out.
And I had to call him, he
was the only number I had,
and the only person, you know?
So, it just crazy how the universe works.
But he actually answered
and he took me back.
But we only we only lived
together for like a month,
and we broke up again.
- [Mark] But he helped
you out in that situation?
- Yes. It's a blessing that he
actually picked up the phone
at like two in the morning.
I was at the strip club.
She made me strip make money and stuff.
I was making $1,000 dollars a day,
and like, days where she
wasn't even making that much,
and she'd get so jealous an pissed off,
and like, she thought I
liked her pimp boyfriend.
Which, I never even hooked up
with him until she made me.
So, it's just like, you
know, she was trippin.
She was on a good one.
But I ran away, I ended up calling him.
I used the taxi driver, 'cause
she got sick one morning.
I think she got pregnant or something.
(laughs)
But she was like throwing up and stuff,
and she's like, "You go to work."
'Cause she finally trusted me, I guess.
I was making so much money
and I wasn't complaining,
you know what I mean?
I was there for at least a month or two.
- [Mark] And with that
short period of time,
you were bringing the money
and giving it to them?
- Oh, yeah, they would take all my money,
and leave me with like
a few ones in my wallet.
And I'd be like, you know?
And every time I ate, it's like, with her.
Every time I fuck someone, she knew.
Every time I was at work
she's like watching me,
'cause she works there.
Or she'd have people watching me.
- [Mark] Wow.
- It was just so weird.
- [Mark] So, you have your
own stories of debauchery.
- I was so desperate, and
young, and like, lonely,
that I just-
And I kinda, honestly, I was curious.
I wanted to learn how to make-
'cause I was being a high
end escort by myself.
I never was a stripper.
I never was like, going on those websites
where girls go on and doing any of that.
And she kind of, she brought me,
and introduced me to all of that.
And I made so much money.
So, I've been, since then
I've been making at least 1,000
every day when I'm working.
I feel like that's good money.
I could make more modeling,
and like selling, doing
porn or something, but.
- [Mark] That's pretty good and it's-
- That's a lot of like
that's just a lot for me,
like, I don't know if I really
want my pictures out there like that.
I did porn one time
and I only made $1,000,
and the girl that it was for,
she made like, so much money.
You know what I mean?
It's just, I don't like
to feel that way, like-
kind of taken advantage
of in that situation.
So I just would rather go see
someone real quick for 1,000.
(laughs)
Nobody knows about it.
- [Mark] You seem very
happy with your life.
- It could be better.
I really want like, a nice, you know,
estate or mansion or something.
- [Mark] For 25 years old, I think your-
- Is it good?
- [Mark] Your doing pretty good.
- Thank you. Awe, thanks.
- [Mark] Very interesting perspective
on this life that you lead.
Yeah, 'cause I've-
- Maybe it's because I'm around
older people all the time
that I feel like I need to be like,
driving the Ferrari too, and the mansion,
I need to be like going on the trips.
- [Mark] I've heard a
wide range of stories
from the most tragic you can imagine
to something like yours
which is one of the nicest,
most pleasant, less traumatic,
stories I've heard.
And,
- Thank you.
- [Mark] you still have some stories-
- Well, I've just been
through so much things
that I just feel like
this is most appealing way
for me to live right now.
'Cause I could dance,
I could sing karaoke.
I could massage.
I like to dress up, I love traveling.
I like flirting, I like
drinking, like smoking.
I like meeting people.
- [Mark] I think your personality also
is also a huge part of
your success, perhaps.
- I, people tell me all the time,
that like, I make probably the most money
because of my personality.
- [Mark] This career
is not for every girl.
- Probably not.
I've seen some girls,
like, not really into it,
but I'm always into it.
I try to make the best of every situation.
(laughs)
- [Mark] All right, Oceanian.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] And good luck with
whatever you do from here.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thanks.
- Aye, was it lit?
- [Mark] You did great.